en cinquième position c'est draguer sans
draguer
c'est à dire être normal et sympa
oubliez la drague frontale type je te
mets de la crème solaire on sort
ensemble ce soir il faut y aller
doucement d'accord doucement d'accord
donc ça va peut-être même le ça sable tu
vois est-ce que tu aimes bien les algues
voilà la première étape c'est de briser
la glace
il y a pas de recette miracle pour ça un
sourire tu vois voilà une phrase
d'accroche réfléchie sous-entendu du
type eh il fait chaud aujourd'hui quelle
chance
c'est la technique numéro 5 vraiment
vous démarrez comme ça
après en quatre faut proposer des
activités voler baignade raquette
couillubinage si vous passe par la tête
tout est bon pour créer du lien donc
ouais les filles les filles on se fait
voler
les filles qui veut jouer à raquette
aime les quéquette
[Applaudissements]
normalement il y a pas de marche tout
noir
après la technique de la mi-perdu c'est
une technique qui peut fonctionner l'ami
perdue c'est comme le pain c'est quoi ça
[Rires]
et en fait vous devez rejoindre sur la
place vous n'avez plus de batterie ça ou
bien alors vous êtes comme ça Patrick
pas tout et donc là il y a une meuf
excusez-moi un pote Patrick mais j'ai
plus de batterie est-ce que je pourrais
emprunter votre propre portable
voilà et donc et donc vous appelez
jamais l'ami perdue bah si tu fais genre
tu appelles l'ami perdue donc personne
connaît les numéros par cœur bah si moi
si à part vous personne que d'un numéro
de l'imagination
puis vous engager une conversation
et en fait pourquoi vous avez le pote
vous avez réfléchissez les mecs quoi
est-ce que vous appelez vraiment un pote
non vous appelez vous-même mais non mais
pas du tout donc vous connaissez pas
remarquer ou bien toi tu t'appelles
toi-même parce que là numéro de la meuf
voilà oui après tu peux l'appeler
attends attends attends
attends
le numéro
que Patrick
c'est pas con ça non oui mais ça peut
être ça ensuite
vous allez vous baigner vous avez envie
que quelqu'un jette un coup d'oeil sur
vos affaires
demandez-lui gentiment si elle va je
suis tout seul surveiller
[Rires]
hein
regardez mes affaires merci
et là tu vas te baigner la meuf garde
tes affaires après faut rentrer dans
l'eau vachement bien parce que rentre
dans l'eau comme une merde
[Applaudissements]
tu m'as pris pour ton lapin pas du tout
truc de ça exactement
tu crois vraiment que je t'explique mon
lapin Bastien range mes affaires
ah il y a aussi joué au ballon près de
la personne sans faire exprès envoyer
lui le ballon dessus
je pardonner invité à manger une glace
de boule
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
on y arrive on y arrivera pas alors je
vous dis on y arrivera pas non mais
sérieux donc quoi vous pensez vraiment
que toutes ces techniques à ça ça
fonctionne vous êtes fous quoi
normal comment vous faites pour draguer
comment vous faites que vous voulez mais
admettons
la meilleure activité c'est très
n'oubliez jamais cette phrase c'est pas
la technique je suis là elle te suit
celui-là elle te fuit la meilleure
technique c'est de fuir j'ai le fait
très bien
le problème c'est que lui il fait
tellement loin que ça va non mais c'est
vrai les mecs c'est ça la technique je
vous le dis regardez on est bien sûr
mais ça marche quand elle est un peu
accroché déjà si elle est pas si tu la
connais pas comment tu fais pas
l'intérêt
il faut se faire désirer voilà
j'y arrive pas
tout par exemple avec Fatou comment tu
l'as dragué
à mon avis à mon avis à mon avis ça
marche la voix
[Rires]
le physique à la voix alors en fait je
l'ai repéré dans une soirée j'ai tourné
autour d'elle pendant toute la soirée
par la lecture
voilà technique du cercle concentrique
petit à petit je me suis approché d'elle
l'escargot la frôlé elle a été obligée
d'engager la conversation et soit ça
soit la police j'ai eu de la chance
infaillible c'est un canapé et un
journal tourner comme ça vous tournez et
puis après vous dites comment tu
t'appelles comment tu t'appelles comment
tu t'appelles Fatou Fatou Fatou Fatou
[Applaudissements]
mis
c'est génial mais c'est génial non mais
elle est gentille Fatou hein
[Applaudissements]
tu peux draguer comme ça
je t'ai réveillé
merci
[Rires]
à deux copines aussi quand il y a deux
meufs faut se mettre sur l'autre meuf la
meuf avec qui on veut pas sortir comme
ça ça suscite un sentiment de jalousie
et au dernier moment on opère ce qu'on
appelle le grand switch et là on se
balance on se met sur l'autre meuf et on
lui prononce une phrase subtile genre
lâche ton snap bébé et là
bébé
des fois ça m'est arrivé quand même
c'est du vécu ça ouais ça m'arrivait
avec un ami le grand switch j'étais il y
avait il y avait deux démons il y avait
il y avait un ami proche
vous avez beaucoup de gens en fait il y
avait une meuf très belle il y avait une
meuf quelconque
et il peut nous raconter cette histoire
[Rires]
mais il a pas fini
parce qu'ils font les malins
ils vont pleurer donc
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
allez on passe à autre chose on passe à
autre chose